a promising new treatment could help
children suffering from peanut allergies
immune therapeutics says research shows
the daily use of its protein of peanut
protein capsules could desensitize
children to the allergy but there are
still some hurdles to overcome before
the drug hits your medicine cabinet our
dr. Jon LaPook looks at the potential
benefits Jon good morning good morning
Nora this is a huge problem for our
nation's kids more than a million
children in the u.s. suffer from peanut
allergies which can range from mild to
extremely severe for many parents a
daily medicine that could ward off an
allergy attack would be a life changer
for them and their kids 12 year old
Aidan Robertson and his mother Lisa
didn't know he was allergic until he was
two years old and ate peanut butter it's
horrifying moment when you see your
child all of a sudden his face was
swelling and swelling and swelling
doctors quickly treated Aidan with an
antihistamine but every day the
Robertsons are on guard against an
allergy attack avoiding any food that
might contain peanuts and peanut oil -
you don't know how many things that's
actually in and it's in a lot of things
now a company called immune is offering
a new assault against peanut allergies
in its study it gave increasingly larger
doses of peanut protein powder sprinkled
over food to nearly 500 children aged 4
to 17 at the end of six months
67 percent of them were able to tolerate
the equivalent of roughly two peanuts
enough to avoid a potentially deadly
reaction to a small accidental exposure
it changes the way the immune system
sees peanut so it changes it from seeing
it as something dangerous to something
that is safe dr. Jonathan Tam is a
pediatric allergy specialist who help
recruit test subjects for the company
it's not gonna be for everybody but for
certain families that are very anxious
having accidental exposures this is a
great therapy for them the company's
findings have not yet been reviewed by
independent experts I'd be very
interested to see you know further
documentation on this study and
and kind of what what comes of it before
we would jump in there are some risks
when you take the drug it can cause
reactions to peanut stomach pains mouth
itching up to 19 percent of the kids had
to drop out from the study because of
these side effects still Aiden says he'd
love to worry less about his peanut
allergy especially on one day in
particular it's been hard because half
of my Halloween candy is gone all the
peanut stuff is out the window oh we can
all have empathize with that now this
isn't an all-out cure we're still far
from letting kids with severe allergies
eat all their peanut filled Halloween
candy the company plans to file for
approval by the FDA administration by
the end of the year promising it dosnt
promising you know there I'm hearing
cautiously optimistic but for parents
can you imagine the nightmare for them
watching huge relief a Snickers bar is
something that is something to behold
and beheld yeah
I'm hungry thanks John